[Musique]
l'hebdo politique bonsoir à tous et
bienvenue dans l'hebdo politique sur
radio sensations diffusée également sur
pv 78 épisodes 205 ce soir mon invité et
karl olive
les politiques
[Musique]
car le livre bonsoir bonsoir quentin
vous êtes le maire divers droite de
poissy et vice président du conseil
départemental des yvelines avant
d'entrer dans le monde politique vous
étiez d'abord journaliste d'abord à yves
une première puis à canal+ vous avez un
temps dirigé le service des sports dans
le foot vous avez été le président de
plusieurs clubs de l'achat tout de l'aes
poissy dans les yvelines vous avez
également connu une expérience un peu
moins réussie est plus courte à la c b
le club de boulogne-billancourt dans les
hauts-de-seine dans votre engagement
politique ensuite vous n'avez pas
effacer cette fibre sportif qui vous
caractérisent que représente pour vous
le sport dans la vie de tous les jours
d'abord merci pour l'invitation
le sport c'est l'école de la vie quand
on est imbibé aux règles du jeu à la
minute vous prenez votre licence vous
savez que le sport va être un espèce de
viatique qui va conduire votre histoire
moi vous savez je suis issu d'une
famille nombreuse nous étions 800
garçons et une fille on a toujours fait
du sport et notre notre pain finalement
au quotidien c'était d'aller taper dans
la balle au pied de l'immeuble dans le
quartier populaire de la coudraie et
puis j'ai toujours été sportif comme ma
famille a toujours été sportif ma soeur
est aujourd'hui présidente du comité
olympique brigitte henriques et quand
j'ai été élu en 2014 à la ville de
poissy j'ai d'abord respecter l'ensemble
des agents en les rassemblant et en leur
rappelant les règles du jeu et les
règles du jeu c'est comme dans le sport
vous appliquez les règles vous les
interpréter pas vous êtes dans le jeu où
vous êtes en dehors du jeu et ça
fonctionne très bien pour annoncer un
arbitre comme vous ce n'est pas étonnant
vous êtes un homme de médias un homme du
sport est un homme politique enfin voilà
certainement pourquoi une mission
gouvernementale vous a été confié votre
objectif trouver des solutions pour
l'insertion par le sport des habitants
et notamment des jeunes dans les
quartiers populeux prioritaire de la
politique de la ville vous devrez rendre
vos conclusions le 11 janvier prochain
cela vous a fait plaisir que l'on pense
à vous pour remplir cette mission
d'abord j'ai pas mis trente secondes
avant d'accepter pourquoi parce que on
voit bien aujourd'hui que le sport fait
partie intégrante du quotidien de nos
jeunes quel qu'il soit là on va parler
quartiers populaires ce qu'on appelle
les quartiers en politique de la ville
mais je dirais qu'on va même élargir le
périmètre il n'y a pas besoin d'être
seulement quartier pour de politique de
la ville pour pour aimer le sport pour
faire du sport pour s'insérer par le
sport le sport c'est magnifique d'en
voir les vertus vertus sanitaires
pendant un an et demi nos gamins ont
pris du poids ils ont été a dicté depuis
aux jeux vidéo playstation etc vous en
savez quelque chose ils n'ont pas
attendu le coup vide mais aujourd'hui ça
s'est creusé ensuite ce qu'on constate
c'est que nos jeunes ont déserté cqfd
les associations ce parti et sportive
dans lesquelles il il appartenait il
faut les faire revenir dans les clubs
sportifs justement pour avoir ce côté
adossé à la vertu du sport mais aussi à
la vertu de la discipline du respect des
règles enfin le sport est aussi un moyen
d'insertion vers l'emploi et ça ça me
paraît très important aujourd'hui dans
nos quartiers populaires il y a deux
fois moins de jeunes qui ont accès aux
clubs sportifs parce que justement ils
sont pas forcément suffisamment
accompagner et quand vous n'êtes pas
accompagné c'est la porte ouverte à
plein de choses y compris à des bêtises
y compris à des incivilités alors cette
mission évidemment qu'elle m'a fait
plaisir parce que je suis né dans les
quartiers populaires je crois pouvoir
dire que le sport a toujours été un un
bagage qui a toujours été à mes côtés
depuis que je suis je suis môme on va
rien inventer corentin on va réinventer
on va simplement voir ce qui fonctionne
voir ce qui ne fonctionne pas et voir ce
qu'on peut préconiser et pour cela il
faut aller sur le terrain moi c'est mon
adn donc je vais me promener dans les
douze belles régions de france et faire
aussi une escale en outre-mer parce que
je veux que ce soit le terrain qui parle
lorsque je rendrai mes conclusions comme
vous l'avez dit à la mi janvier 2022
vous avez dit vous allez aller mais qui
est ce que vous allez rencontrer alors
j'ai déjà démarré pour rencontrer des
acteurs des acteurs de terrain moi je
veux aller voir par exemple des mamans
qui ont des initiatives du côté
de roubaix qui permet de justement à ces
jeunes de sortir parfois du quartier je
veux aller également dans un quartier de
toulouse ou au travers par exemple de la
boxe des jeunes sont intégrés et
parfaitement intégré et insérés dans le
tissu social hier j'ai rencontré une
association qui s'appelle associations
appellent ce cas une très belle idée
donc l' agence pour l'insertion par le
sport qu'à une très belle idée c'est de
mettre en place des coachs par
l'insertion par le sport qu'est ce que
c'est c'est tout simplement d'aller
chercher dénicher des pépites alors pas
des pépites pour être footballeur
professionnel ou des pépites pour être
rugbyman professionnel mais simplement
des pépites qui vont identifier celles
et ceux qui ont un profil pour pouvoir
les accompagner dans le travail et une
fois qu'elles ont trouvé un boulot il ya
du partenariat avec la pence et bien
c'est les suivre effectivement dans le
travail comme j'aime à dire dans nos
collectivités ici à elancourt comme
comme ailleurs évidemment qu'on embauche
on embauche également des jeunes mais
parfois des jeunes qui n'ont jamais
travaillé on va s'apercevoir que deux
semaines après il sort tard au travail
trois semaines après ils vont pas venir
on sait pas pourquoi ils ont besoin peu
de tuteurs voiliers et les tuteurs de
confiance donc celles et ceux en qui ils
se ressemblent mais c'est un peu ce que
propose la pesc oui ça ça fera
certainement partie des préconisations
que je ferai à l'état au mois de janvier
prochain alors comme autre initiative je
ne décèle de la ligue de paris de
football cette dernière a lancé à partir
de cette année en partenariat avec les
clubs de football francilien des
formations en apprentissage pour obtenir
le bmf le brevet de moniteur de football
ce diplôme permet ensuite d'entraîner
des équipes de foot au niveau
départemental en ce moment il ya une
tendance à développer au maximum les
contrats en apprentissage
ces contrats dans le monde du sport sait
quelque chose à développer pour
l'insertion alors c'est pas moi que vous
allez
me dire que l'apprentissage est une
vertu cardinale de ce que nous devons
faire et notamment en direction des
jeunes et et je salue radio sensations
pour continuer à faire de
l'apprentissage comme vous le faites si
bien pour moi l'apprentissage ça
passeport pour l'emploi vraiment c'est
un véritable passeport pour l'emploi bon
une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est que
l'initiative de jamel sandjak le
président de la ligue de football
professionnel de france va évidemment
dans ce dans ce sens là je vais
rencontrer raymond domenech l'ancien
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france qu'a
mis en place dès bafa pour le football
n'en parle vous me parlez d'éducateurs
pour le football et c'est très bien
parce qu'il faut éduquer nos entraîneurs
nos dirigeants qu'ils ne sont pas
suffisamment
raymond domenech propose également de
former des jeunes pour le bafa football
c'est formidable parce qu'aujourd'hui un
jeune qui va faire son bafa son brevet
d'aptitude aux fonctions d'animateur
pour voir ensuite encadrés pendant les
vacances par exemple des stages de
football ce qui est pas possible
aujourd'hui puisque ne sont pas
forcément formés et donc ils n'ont pas
le bafa vous voyez comme je dis il n'y a
pas de petites n'y a pas de grandes
idées il ya de belles idées et
n'oublions pas que là on parle football
on a donné deux exemples ma mission
n'est pas simplement cerner autour du
football et les cerner dans superman
jeunes autour du sport en général vous
avez raison on va en parler du sport en
général deux types de france olympique a
remporté 33 médailles aux jo de tokyo
cet été c'est 9 de moins qu'à rio en
2016 est-ce que ce résultat vous à un
petit peu déçue
la mieux placée pour en parler c'est ma
soeur c'est brigitte henriques la
présidente du comité national olympique
sportif français
moi j'ai le coeur qui vibre à chaque
fois qu'il ya une marseillaise j'ai le
coeur qui vibre à chaque fois que il ya
une médaille de bronze une médaille
d'argent et une médaille d'or j'ai un
passionné de sport donc mon coeur il
fait boum boum boum boum c'est ça qui
m'a plu y compris à tokyo et notamment
dans les sports collectifs dans les
sports collectifs on est un certainement
l'un ou le meilleur pays au monde c'est
formidable cap à cap capitalisons sur
justement ce qui va bien et puis
améliorant ce qui va un peu moins bien
et ce dont on s'aperçoit c'est que
peut-être que la déception que vous
rappelez sur le fait qu'on ait fait
moins de médailles
vient peut-être du fait qu' il n'y a pas
eu assé d'accompagnement justement avant
les jo de tokyo de très grande qualité
ou en tout cas d'accompagnement fluide
il faut investir dans l'accompagnement
il faut investir dans les entraîneurs
c'est aussi cela la formation à la
française mon petit doigt me dit que
c'est aussi dans ce sens là que tony
estanguet que les équipes qui
l'entourent que brigitte en caisse vont
aller d'ici 2024 parce que il est
important à côté des acteurs de terrain
que sont nos championnes et nos
champions qu'il soit parfaitement
organisé et je dis aussi parfaitement
accompagné on va peut-être parler de ce
qui s'est passé après si cette semaine
avec les 250 nageurs gamins du
département qui sont venus autour de
champion olympique j'ai discuté avec des
champions olympiques de natation ian et
qu'agnel mehdy metella ou une championne
d'europe qui s'appelle fantine lesaffre
leur sujet c'est évidemment de pouvoir
vivre de leur de leur passion ils sont
champions olympiques ils doivent
toujours allait être proactif pour aller
chercher du financement à un moment
donné on ne peut pas tout faire il faut
qu'on reste un focus sur son coeur de
métier ce qu'on demande à yannick agnel
à mehdi metella à la jeune fantine
lesaffre c'est d'être champion olympique
c'est d'être des très très grand
champion peut-être un peu moins d'aller
chercher le financement qui doivent pour
leur permet de le devenir ça c'est c'est
le politique qui va gérer ça la france
est elle un pays de sportifs dans le nul
la france est un pays de sportifs la
france est un des grands pays de sport
avec des installations qui sont des
installations merveilleuse et qui vont
être décuplé avec le programme de 2,5
milles dispositif et notamment de
dispositifs de proximité faut quand même
envie on va reparler s'il faut quand
même le signaler peut-être pas
suffisamment il ya cinquante ans que le
plan bill piscine avait été avait été
créée donc là il faut je pense qu'il
faut massivement investir pour notamment
par et 2024 on va y revenir certainement
la france est un pays sportif évidemment
avec de très grands champions il faut
pas simplement garder le spectre sur la
cerise sur le gâteau il faut aussi
s'occuper du gâteau est à mon avis plus
encore que qu'aujourd'hui ça signifie
quoi ça signifie justement que il faut
aller chercher ces jeunes et ces jeunes
corentin il faut aller les chercher
entre 6 et 10 ans derrière c'est presque
perdu il faut que aujourd'hui on est
presque mais mort tard en 2021 2024
c'est demain on a un héritage à préparer
et je redis que nos gamins depuis un an
et demi ont pris du poids les mêmes qui
peut-être dans cinq ans dans six ans
dans dix ans seront ceux qui auront
gagné des médailles d'or il a eu à une
urgence de la situation faire en sorte
non seulement on rappelle que le sport
c'est l'école de la vie mais c'est
vraiment montrer que le sport doit être
partie intégrante
de l'éducation de nos enfants plus de
sport à l'école dans les collèges dans
les lycées plus de classes à horaires
aménagés sport plus de classes à
horaires aménagés comme on en a à la
cité scolaire le corbusier ça fonctionne
magnifiquement bien il faut faire
confiance aux sports quand on fait
confiance aux sports on n'est jamais
déçu c'est pendant qu'ils disent et les
statistiques qui le montre la france un
pays de deux sportifs donc pourtant on
parle peu de sport dans les différents
programmes de campagne en tout cas pour
la présidentielle 2022 on parle beaucoup
écologie migration sécurité mais très
peu de sport finalement pour l'année
prochaine ministère des sports verra son
budget augmenter de 22% il passera à 987
millions d'euros c'est un budget qui a
toujours augmenté au cours du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron il était
en 2018 on le rappelle de 481 millions
d'euros on voit un petit peu l'évolution
peut mais pourtant c'est toujours entre
guillemets que 0 point 3 % du budget de
l'état alors car le dis parce qu'on peut
vraiment se considérer comme un pays de
sportifs quand 0 3 % de notre budget est
consacré au sport la réussite du sport
et des sportifs c'est pas seulement une
équation financière ça va être aussi une
équation de visibilité ou je vous
rejoins c'est que on a l'impression
qu'il ya beaucoup de tuyaux qui
permettent d'aller chercher des
subventions dans différents ministères
et que finalement les associations
sportives les clubs on parle de sport
mais on pourrait parler d'autres
structures comme les structures de
loisirs les structures culturelles ne
savent pas où aller où je vous rejoins
c'est qu'il faut qu'on ait vraiment une
traçabilité qui soit bien plus bien ce
blog bien plus lisible aujourd'hui si on
nous demande comment bénéficier d'un
certain nombre de subventions on sait
pas où aller les chercher il nous faut
absolument faire en sorte que l'ensemble
de ces tuyaux ne fassent qu'un en tout
cas c'est le voeu que je forme et c'est
ce sur quoi je vais travailler pour
pour l'état dans la mission aussi qui
est la mienne dans les premiers retours
que j'ai de terrain c'est justement ce
côté un peu trouble sur le fait de à qui
dois-je m'adresser la porte d'entrée
quelle est elle c'est le ministère des
sports parce qu'on parle de compétition
c'est le ministère du travail parce
qu'on parle d'insertion par le sport
c'est le ministère de la santé parce
qu'on parle du sport santé vous voyez
bien que le sport c'est pas simplement
un seul tuyau qui remonte au ministère
des sports avec un budget qui a augmenté
certes il est peut-être pas suffisant
mais en tout cas il a augmenté depuis
cinq ans qui s'était pas produit depuis
une vingtaine d'une vingtaine d'années
maintenant mais il faut absolument qu'on
ait plus de lisibilité sur sur le sujet
donc pour répondre à votre question oui
le budget a augmenté il faut absolument
faire en sorte que l'on ait une espèce
de tronc commun ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui devant les médaillés
olympiques le président emmanuel macron
a annoncé le 13 septembre dernier la
création d'un plan d'équipement à
l'horizon des jeux 2024 c'est le plan
5000 terrain de sport 200 millions
d'euros répartis sur trois ans seront
consacrés à la construction ou là où à
la requalification de 5000 équipements
sportifs de proximité principalement
dans les quartiers prioritaires de la
ville que pensez vous de ce plan alors
ça c'est très intéressant c'est ce que
j'ai dit au président de la république
très intéressant à pau si on les a mis
en place dès 2017 le stadium loris à
londres par exemple eysseric horta août
ne s'était pas de sébastien chabal ce
qui est intéressant en plus pardon de le
dire mais quand on fait de la politique
on est aussi redevable des données
publiques c'est que on a réussi à
obtenir 80 % de subventions sur les
trois équipements qu'on a mis en place
alors c'est intéressant parce que
d'abord c'est au coeur des quartiers
c'est intéressant parce que les gamins
qui veulent pas aller en sport qui ne
veulent pas de licence poehl peuvent
occuper ces dispositifs quand ils le
souhaitent c'est un peu à la méthode
espagnole ou du matin jusqu'à minuit on
peut on peut prendre jusqu'à ça c'est
très intéressant c'est très intéressant
mais ce n'est pas suffisant l'objectif
c'est aussi que ces jeunes puissent
retrouver le chemin
le chemin des clubs et in fine est
arrivé à quitter à quitter le quartier
en tout cas c'est ce que je pense donc
ça c'est très bien pour rester dans le
quartier et comme j'aime à dire quand
nos jeunes sont sur le terrain du matin
au soir ils sont par ailleurs pour faire
des bêtises par exemple mais il faut
aussi les accompagner à la fois vers les
clubs de sport et justement derrière
pour pouvoir embrayer sur l'insertion
par l'emploi au travers du sport jusqu'à
présent l'état accompagné
prioritairement des grands équipements
en faible quantité dont les usagers sont
parfois éloignés avec ce plan l'état
subventionnera des city stade des
terrains de basket 3 x 3 on a vu cette
nouvelle épreuve aux jo de tokyo des
terrains de proximité donc immédiate des
lieux de vie ou de de travail c'est un
changement stratégie radicale pourquoi
aujourd'hui c'est important de ne pas
oublier cet aspect de proximité du sport
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
corentin parce que effectivement le
sentiment que j'ai c'est que le logiciel
se remet à l'endroit alors à l'endroit
de l'air heureux de notre société
finalement c'est une décision darwiniste
c'est à nous à nous mettre au niveau de
la société pâle inverse l'épidémie l'a
montré et on a de nouveaux usages qui
sont demandées par nos jeunes dans les
quartiers et il faut répondre à ces
nouveaux usages et les les dispositifs
de proximité les city-stade l'estrie
corta août donc les sports en liberté
comme on les appelle à l'extérieur font
partie de ces nouveaux usages mais au
delà et manière quand je vois les
opérations coeur de ville pour sortir un
tout petit peu du sport c'était la même
chose coeur de ville la différence avec
ce qu'on connaissait auparavant c'est
qu'auparavant parler de plans car de
plans quartier on ouvrez le robinet au
sommet de l'état on donnait 500 millions
à toutes les communes qui avaient
découpé vais donc des quartiers
politique de la ville et on regardait
pas la nature des projets aujourd'hui
ces projets de l'avenir du terrain ont
fait remonter les usa les usages de
terrain on a un projet et l'état
on va réfléchir sur le projet et donner
un financement qui égare au projet ça
c'est très intéressant c'est ce qui se
passe avec ces nouveaux usages donc je
trouve que l'état finalement se met à
l'heure de ce qui se passe sur sur le
terrain ça signifie aussi que l'état se
déplace sur le terrain et ça c'est bien
parce qu'on l'a souvent reproché aux
gouvernants de nouvelles de pas le faire
cette année le gouvernement justement à
lancer une nouvelle aide financière pour
le sport le pass'sport pour inciter les
familles à emmener les enfants dans les
clubs l'une est une allocation de 50
euros est accordée donc par enfant pour
une inscription dans une association
sportive il fallait relancer le sport
après le coup vide alors il fallait
relancer le sport il fallait surtout
donner du pouvoir d'achat aux familles
je vois ce qu'on fait à poissy encore
une fois depuis 2016 2017 avait
justement ce passeport est ce pass
culture qu'on a mis en place donc il ya
déjà bientôt quatre ans c'est quoi c'est
30 euros par famille parent enfant qui
entre 12 ans et 17 ans s'inscrit dans
une association sportive de la ville de
poissy ou dans une association
culturelle feront soir la mairie par la
mairie sans condition de ressources la
seule contrepartie c'est qu'on veut
simplement un acte citoyen c'est-à-dire
d'être des citoyens je veux pas dire
modèle mais entre guillemets normaux
c'est ce que j'appelle la réciprocité
entre les droits et les devoirs en
respectant sa aucune difficulté vous
avez quatre enfants vous êtes 4 x 320
cent vingt 120 euros l'état va dans ce
sens là et ça peut être complétée
d'ailleurs par les aides de l'état
simplement l'étape mais un passeport
choix c'est 50 euros par part par enfant
sous conditions de ressources donc c'est
bien aussi
j'aurais aimé aussi que j'ai cette
petite contrepartie qui fasse que si
jamais le gamin qui a 12 ans se
retrouvent à 2 heures du matin a cassé à
l'abribus en suspens ces aides ne paraît
important qu'on soit dans un contrat
gagnant gagnant mais évidemment que ça
va dans le bon sens c'est pas simplement
pour que nos jeunes retrouvent le chemin
des des clubs c'est pour que les
familles et du pouvoir d'achat et
aujourd'hui vous savez que le pouvoir
d'achat est au coeur justement de des
français de skill de ce qu'il manque et
de ce qu'ils réclament et je trouve que
pour le coup le gouvernement a
parfaitement raison d'aller en ce sens
là le sport c'est malheureusement aussi
de la violence cette semaine le match
nice marseille a été rejouée à 3 des
incidents avec les supporters niçois
avaient causé l'interruption du match à
nice fin août en tant que membre du
conseil d'administration de la lfp vous
aviez alors demandé à ce que des
sanctions draconiennes soient prises le
supporters niçois qui avait frappé le
joueur de l'olympique de marseille
dimitri payet a été condamné à un an de
prison avec sursis et cinq ans
d'interdiction de stade c'est un bon
message qui a été envoyé alors rappeler
simplement corentin que pour pour aller
jusqu'au bout de votre phrase que le
match disputé à trois était à huis clos
donc là pour le coup il n'y a pas eu il
ya pas eu de problème moi je suis
toujours triste je suis toujours triste
pour le sport et pour pour le football
et je suis triste pour le public de voir
une bande d'illuminés une bande de
voyous une bande de cours on
pardonnez-moi venir pourrir un sport
comme ils pourrissent la société c'est
toujours une minorité
qui vient finalement polluer le
quotidien d'une grande majorité
silencieuse dans un stade vous avez 95 %
du public dans un stade qui est là pour
vivre sa passion et ça se passe très
bien et puis vous avez 5 % d'abrutis qui
de toute façon quoi qu'on fasse vont
vouloir ternir est pollué polluer une
rencontre tout pollué une équipe adverse
on l'a encore vu dimanche à marseille et
dieu sait si les marseillais ont
parfaitement je dirais était dans la
prévention en expliquant qu'il fallait
éviter toutes ces incivilités tel muller
de médecine pour on a vu payet on a vu
payet sur les réseaux sociaux prévenir
on l'a vu encore sur le terrain et
pourtant vous aider à des abrutis qui
balancent ddd
des bouteilles et c'est à mon sens il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de vérité
parce que c'est pas une science corentin
il faut rester très humble sur le sujet
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que les
clubs vraiment soit dans un contrat
encore une fois gagnant gagnant avec les
clubs de supporters et que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités c'est aussi aux
clubs de supporters qui connaissent
leurs supporters qui connaissent leurs
ultras d'expliquer que la moindre la
moindre bavure la moindre dérive elle
est avec une sanction immédiate ces
exclusions du du supporter en question
est derrière la justice se doit avancer
alors là on a un an avec sursis et à
quelques milliers d'euros d'euros
d'amendé ça va dans le bon sens je suis
juste déçu typiquement que voilà avec ça
c'est à titre perso que le supporters
qui a couru dimanche en plein match
après abc soit convoqué par la justice
et ressortent avec un rappel à la loi
c'est pas suffisant parce que dix tous
les week-ends on peut avoir des
supporters qui vont donc rentré sur le
terrain faire leur numéro de claquettes
faire une belle photo avec je ne sais
pas qui si ça s'arrête là tant mieux
mais on peut imaginer le pire et
repartir avec un rappel à la loi ça me
paraît insuffisant mais voici c'est la
future ville du psg un club qui vous
tient à coeur on sait le chantier du
futur centre d'entraînement a été
officialisée en 2016 il est estimé entre
250 et 300 millions d'euros le projet
devrait aboutir pour l'été 2023 où en
sont les travaux alors ça avance très
bien justement ce matin en venant en
venant ici dans votre belle belle
station de radio avec avec lester est
l'une de mes collaboratrices on se
faisait à la réflexion de voir que le
chantier avançait mais vraiment à grand
pas et j'invite toutes celles et ceux
qui nous écoutent et nous regardent à
venir simplement voir de l'extérieur
l'ampleur l'ampleur de ce chantier qui
avance avec ses quelques 3000 arbres je
rappelle que ces 92 % des espaces
sensibles et naturel qui vont être mises
en place c'est 1000 emplois pendant la
durée des travaux ces seize terrains de
football c'est le football mais
également le handball et le judo avec
dans une dans un deuxième temps la
création d'un stade de 3 à 5000 places
et c'est effectivement 250 millions
d'euros et puis jean claude blanc le
directeur général du paris saint germain
qui fait un travail exceptionnel
qui au jour le jour nous tient informés
de l'évolution du du chantier enfin je
veux dire que c'est un travail collectif
que ce
centre d'entraînement n'aurait jamais vu
le jour si on n'avait pas travaillé main
dans la main avec le département des
yvelines avec la communauté urbaine
quand paris seine et oise avec la région
ile de france avec les agriculteurs avec
les habitants avec l'état avec la ville
de poissy seul on va plus vite ensemble
on va plus loin qu'est ce que cela va
permettre pour poissy un gain en
notoriété des nouvelles perspectives
pour l'avenir un tout petit exemple nous
sommes aujourd'hui le week-end avant le
1er novembre le 4 novembre jeudi
première pierre de porsche qui vient
installer sa plus grande concession
d'europe en face du paris saint germain
c'est un aspirateur et notre activité
économique à nulle autre pareille c'est
formidable pour le paris saint-germain
c'est formidable pour porsche c'est
formidable pour poissy c'est formidable
pour le territoire parce qu'on parle
d'emploi est notre premier combat doit
être l'emploi dans votre ville de poissy
les agents municipaux ont la possibilité
de faire deux heures de sport par
semaine sur leur temps de travail
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix parce que
je suis convaincu que le sport est un
accélérateur
sanitaire que les vertus du sport on le
dit souvent bensalah in corpore sano un
corps sain dans un esprit sain et il me
semble que lorsque vous avez une ville
de poissy qui n'a pas augmenter sa
pression fiscale qui a diminué enfin qui
a fait 25 % d'économies de
fonctionnement en six ans on le doit
certes à l'impulsion politique mais on
le doit surtout à nos agents qui ont
accepté de relever le défi comment entre
qu'il m'ait récompensé ses agents alors
évidemment il ya les primes qu'on a pu
sortir mais aussi un dispositif qu'on a
mis en place et donc nous offrons deux
heures de sport dans le cadre du temps
de travail par semaine à nos agents on a
mis ce dispositif en place en 2017 on
s'était donné trois ans pour voir si ça
fonctionne ou pas on ne s'est aperçu au
bout d'un mois que c'était tout
simplement extraordinaire puisque
désormais tous les mois tous les cycles
nous avons entre 140 et 200 agents de la
ville de poissy qui participent à ces
créneaux de nage avec palmes de marche
nordique de relaxation de chorales de
renforcement musculaire
amélioration des conditions de travail
d'un côté baisse de l'absentéisme de jeu
de l'autre 750 jours d'absentéisme en
moins sur un an cent mille euros
d'économies cinquante mille euros
réinjecter pour l'amélioration des
conditions de travail on est dans un
contrat gagnant gagnant et je vais plus
loin c'est également une manière d'
accélérer l'insertion sociale avec 60
services différents améliorer également
la relation entre les managers et les
agents quand vous êtes sûr on a
également la chorale quand vous êtes
dans une chorale et que vous avez
quelqu'un qui est membre du cabinet de
la ville de poissy avec un agent des
services techniques avec un agent du
service de l'état civil il n'y a pas de
d'agents n'y a pas de chef ya pas de
membres de cabinets il ya des chanteurs
qui viennent à s'assumer et assouvir
leur passion et ça c'est extraordinaire
enfin j'ajoute que on a plus de femmes
par exemple qui participent à l'ensemble
de ce dispositif que que les hommes et
c'est certainement pas moi qui vais m'en
plaindre ce serait donc une mesure à
généraliser à l'ensemble des communes
alors je j'aimerais alors il ya déjà des
départements qui qu'ils ont mis en place
on la décline également à l'hôpital de
poissy saint germain vous savez j'en
suis le président du conseil de
surveillance et c'est un impact zéro
pour la commune c'est important de le
dire également c'est à dire que puisque
c'est encadré par les éducateurs du
service des sports de la ville de poissy
il n'y a pas d'impact financier c'est
tout simplement extraordinaire et moi je
suis ravi encore une fois d'être dans un
contrat gagnant gagnant on ne peut pas
systématiquement mettre la pression sur
les agents en leur demandant leur
demandant de faire toujours plus avec
moins il faut qu'on soit dans une
relation équitable amélioration des
conditions de travail et puis derrière
baisse de l'absentéisme sylvie on a des
agents qui sont en toujours en pleine
forme et qui ont la banane et ça ça n'a
pas de prix merci beaucoup car le livre
n'est survenu dans l'hebdo politique je
rappelle que vous êtes maire divers
droite de poissy et vice président du
conseil départemental des yvelines nous
on se retrouve dimanche prochain pour un
nouveau numéro de l'hebdo politiques
m'ont invité sera alors ghislaine céder
la présidente du pôle écologiste à la
région ile-de-france très bonne soirée à
tous
l'hebdo politique